Eva was great I actually was movie was
probably a four or five week shoot and
um my part was they they kind of put my
stuff all toward the end of the shoot so
by the time I got there I think it was
the last week pretty pretty sure and uh
boy it was that crew was so devoted to
her she just had this atmosphere uh
fostered that was she got a sense of the
the set the tone that she set absolutely
just just productive and these people
have been working really hard because it
was an ambitious schedule that they had
you know it was a sort of an independent
film there and uh
they were just even though they were you
know pushing to the end the the vibe was
so good they were devoted to her I had a
I had a wonderful time with this crew
and she was so at ease it was felt like
she had been doing this her whole life